we've had a couple good quarters out of
eight so
we've got a lot of work to do
[Music]
the fun yeah the fun thing about it is
you know we have moved the ball at times
very easily
i think we made improvements from week
one to week two
but the biggest thing
is that we're two and up and i know we
owe a lot of that to our defense
aaron rodgers could have gone talk about
swag there but he could have didn't come
on aaron didn't gosh wow are you
watching your friend uh button it up so
uh the green bay packers are two and oh
several other teams two and oh two weeks
in the books but for the monday night
game it's pft live nbc sports radio nbcs
and hello to our friends in the uk and
ireland enjoying the program on sky
sports chris sims mike florio another
hour to try to figure out what in the
world went on yesterday and let's start
with the green bay oh let's start there
your vikings went down
why are you why are you the way you are
i don't know it was 21 like my mom and
dad it was 21-0 green bay packers and
every time the packers scored this guy's
in the nbc viewing room with this
sing-song
crazy italian stereotype voice and you
say it's okay because you're married to
a new jersey i don't know if it's okay
you're not okay
so you picked the cousins it's okay for
me you ate the too much of meatballs and
i went over there in rogers
i'm completely italian in my uh my
all four of my grandparents who uh came
to this country more than a hundred
years ago are probably mortified right
now that their grandchild is
participating in this but that's okay so
the the vikings were down 21-0 and just
like last year when they were in
lambeau field week two dug a hole
and fought and fought and fought their
way out of it yeah
but for a stream of mistakes from the
downfield blocking by dalvin cook that
wiped out a stefan diggs touchdown right
he made the score 21-14 at the half
stefan diggs taking his helmet off after
he scored thinking it was a minneapolis
miracle all over again making the extra
point a 48-yard proposition instead of a
normal 33 yard or missed that it's 2116.
just too many mistakes interception in
the end zone with the game on the line
kirk cousins
can make some big time throws but they
are too few and too far between chris
and we talked about this last hour
there's no intermediate passing game no
for the vikings it's a screen pass or
it's 40 yards down the field you're
exactly right screen pass bomb to digs
or stealing or dalvin cook breaks a big
run right it's one it's one of those
three options right now there is no in
between there's no meat and potatoes of
the vikings offense really for the
second week in a row so that's
concerning and you're right i mean
the game was interesting because and if
you're watching on tv this interception
at the end of the game by kirk cousins
that's just i don't even know what to
say it's inexcusable for somebody at his
point of his career and i'm i'm a
defender of kirk cousins but it's hard
to defend you kirk when you do that it's
first down and you threw a ball you're
its first in goal and you threw a ball
off your back foot into the corner of
the end zone into double coverage and it
was like a 30-yard throw i just don't
get it but you know let me say this let
me just go ahead when they sit down and
they chart all the plays and they look
at the decisions they made in the second
half yeah you know the first half
they're down 21 nothing did they abandon
the run no
and dalvin cook hit a home run yes
right they had that same kind of
desperation in the second half that we
saw from the panthers on thursday night
where they feel like they're one play
away from winning the game even though
there's still plenty of time left they
just keep going the ball run the ball
get back to what is working they feel
like that this one kirk cousins throw is
going to cause the the the green seed
apart yeah they're going to be handed
the super bowl championship right i mean
i feel like they got away from they did
what they want to do and mike zimmer's
got to be upset about that today i would
think so i think what plays into it a
little bit is the green bay playing very
aggressive on the defensive side of the
ball too and the play caller just goes
oh gosh i can't let them keep playing
like man to man bump and run and not
take some shots but you do that is as a
play call you have to back off and go
wait what have we been good at i've been
good at running the ball and our run
system's really good with gary kubiak
there now and dalvin cook right now is
looking like the best player on their
offense so yeah you don't want to forget
that aspect of it but it was a tale of
two games because like the packers could
have been up like 20 they could have
been up 28 31 nothing early on they kind
of blew their chance and then the
vikings kind of dominated and blew their
chance to really come back and really
take the lead or at least tie it up like
you said um
and uh i worry there's a lot of things i
mean we're talking about the vikings
offense i still worry about this packers
offense they're a little the same way
it's the same thing really there's it's
it's they got the run game going it's
either a bomb by rogers and then there's
nothing in between and once they lose
devonte adams like mike zimmer realized
okay wait he's in the throat of devante
adams after the first drive they took
him away who is gonna step up for that
green bay offense to take some pressure
off of devonte adams and aaron rodgers
and we saw it just before halftime if
you had
quarter number six
relationships hey you even said so
yourself when you saw the video of aaron
rodgers he had that look at what was
that he gave it to him yeah
because i think what happened was right
aaron rodgers rolls to his right throws
the ball away and matt lafleur the head
coach must have said something along the
lines mike what the hell are you doing
there erin and uh that's when you could
see aaron well what do you what do you
want me to do well look at him if you're
watching on tv look at him i mean that
it look hey that's gestures that's uh
that's a that's a heart i mean he's not
happy there no he's not well you know
because lefour probably saw somebody
open and he's going well why didn't you
throw to him and he you know roger's
letting him know well i don't know there
was a guy that was 255 pounds running
right at my face so i had to get the
ball out of my hand hey these things go
on a lot i mean come on we've seen all
bet we've seen tom brady cuss out josh
mcdaniels and well have you seen him
cuss out bill belichick no he we have
not yeah checkmate yeah you're right
well yes but it's a different
relationship there that's different but
you know this is not this is normal
banter i'm not sitting here going normal
banter it is there's a lot of banter
like that that goes on between a play
caller
and the quarterback a lot where it's
just hey why didn't you do this hey you
know fu it's you know i did i couldn't
see him or you know to me it looked like
he was covered or i saw this guy
downfield and it looked like his
attention you know so that happens i'm
not gonna make a big deal about it quite
yet okay no because
you are wired at every fiber of your
being no i'm not to make a big deal out
no i'm not i'm just not though because
you have a new friend that you want to
still be your friend we're not friends
okay i hope you will be friends i do i
want to go hang out at this house and
play video games sure i don't even drink
scotch but i'll drink scotch with aaron
rodgers okay but but look here's the
thing the offense is a concern both
teams the offense is a concern yes both
teams the defense is pretty good yes and
the vikings did indeed put the clamps on
the packers in the second half they did
and the packers were very opportunistic
early on and they held off that
onslaught it was a great game it was it
was a sneaky great game right it was
like fun and sloppy and like
yeah it was it was it was there was a
lot of pressure you could it was people
were uptight but let me tell you i mean
at what point do the vikings privately
acknowledge
because it's going to be a while before
they publicly acknowledge it if they
ever do that they got the wrong guy at
quarterback
they're not doing that yet they and i
don't think they have the right guy
quarterback yes i don't have any issue
with the guy at quarterback no again
you just talked about how that was it
was ridiculous to play i get it yes but
i mean damn he did throw a post down in
the middle to stefan diggs that was
phenomenal and made a few other plays
too where i go wow but i'm not going to
say he's the wrong guy at quarterback
they got more issues on that team and
that offense right now than just kirk
cousins you know week one he was fine
what are the issues other than kirk
cousins you tell me what are the issues
well i mean we've seen that they they
have no offense they're they're passing
offense just from what i see as an
executive because of that feeling and
stephan dicks i mean kirk cousins the
guy who's deciding when to throw and who
to throw i get it but they get a
first-time offensive play caller and a
guy in gary kubiak who's there who's not
exactly famous for his passing offense
either so i just look at that and again
it's week two against a very good
defense week one mike he didn't have to
do anything so don't jump on your
quarterback quite yet if he puts another
few performances like we saw here i
might join in on the criticism with you
but it's still early they are one-on-one
um and uh that's all i have to say yeah
they won the game we only threw the ball
10 times yeah well they didn't have to i
mean they're not gonna you can't get mad
at him now because ah dalvin cooks
breaking runs and we're playing good
defense kirk cousin still stinks that's
not fair you just have to wonder what
the teams
are think
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports